>>> MAN, I HAVE BEEN FEELING
GOOD LATELY.
JUST HEALTHY, WHOLE.
>> I'VE BEEN FEELING FUEGO.
>> LOOKING FUEGO TOO.
>> IT'S IMPORTANT AS WE GET
OLDER WE START TAKING CARE OF
OURSELVES.
>> WELLNESS, IT'S SO IMPORTANT.
>> MY BIG THING I'M TRYING TO
CRACK IS MY SCREEN TIME.
RIGHT NOW I'M UP TO 23 1/2 HOURS
A DAY.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> YOU'VE GOT TO DO BETTER.
>> THAT'S NOT GREAT.
>> I'VE BEEN TRYING TO GET IN
SHAPE.
HAVE YOU HEARD OF INTERMITTENT
FASTING?
>> YEAH, ARE YOU DOING THAT?
>> NO, INTERMITTENT SLEEPING.
TUESDAYS, WEDNESDAYS, THURSDAYS
I'M NOT SLEEPING.
>> IS IT WORKING?
>> NOT YET.
>> I'VE GOT THIS POST-WORKOUT
SMOOTHIE I'VE BEEN LOVING.
>> WHAT'S IN IT?
>> MILK, ICE CREAM, CHOCOLATE
SAUCE.
>> A MILKSHAKE?
>> YEAH, A MILKSHAKE, WHY?
WHAT DID I SAY?
>> WE'RE DOING SO WELL.
>> WHAT'S UP?
>> FEELING KIND OF MISERABLE.
>> HOW MISERABLE?
>> THE WORST.
>> I'M ON A NEW MEDICATION.
>> THAT'S GREAT.
>> IT'S LIKE ZOLOFT BUT JUST THE
SIDE EFFECTS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> HUH.
>> VERY DEPRESSED BUT MY PENIS
IS BROKEN.
>> THAT SUCKS.
>> I SIGNED UP FOR A NEW GYM.
IT'S CALLED CIGARETTE FITNESS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> OH MY GOSH, A SMOKING GYM?
>> A SMOKING GYM, THAT'S RIGHT.
>> DUDE, DID YOU KNOW YOU CAN
BLEAT MONEY FROM YOUR BANK
ACCOUNT?
>> GOD, WE ARE DOING SO WELL
RIGHT NOW.
>> TOTALLY, WE'RE SLIPPING AWAY.
>> EVER SINCE THE PANDEMIC, THE
LIGHT KEEPS GETTING DIMMER.
>> DIMMER, FADING, YEAH.
>> I'VE FORGOTTEN HOW TO DANCE.
>> REMEMBER DANCING?
>> NO.
>> IT WAS LIKE --
>> I DON'T KNOW WHY WE EVER DID
THAT.
>> OH, I'VE BEEN SEEING A
THERAPIST.
>> REALLY?
>> LIKE ALL OVER THE PLACE.
I DON'T THINK SHE'S REALLY
THERE.
>> OH, LIKE A HALLUCINATION?
>> I'M TRYING TO KICK ALL MY BAD
HABITS.
I'VE GOT TO STOP GRINDING MY
TEETH.
>> OH!
>> YOU LOOK LIKE GOLLUM.
>> THE DAY I GO TO THE PARK,
TAKE OFF ALL MY CLOTHES AND
START SCREAMING ABOUT HOW
THERE'S TOO MANY WIRES IN THE
WORLD.
>> ONE DAY IS ALL WE ASK.
♪ JUST ONE DAY ♪
>> HA HA HA!
>> WELLNESS BROUGHT TO YOU BY
ORAL-B MOUTH GUARD.
CHND A